okay so this one it's called gotcha
that's another LSP episode and okay so I
sort of got confused
okay so lumpy Space Princess Turturro
princess are talking about how to show
off their lungs and she was gonna she's
gonna write a book about it pertain to
be a secretary for Finn and Jake but why
would she pretend to be a secretary for
finish ish she was gonna write a book to
show turtle princess how to be like
lumpy Space Princess okay you're known
and she was gonna try to show off to
Finn and Jake so she could give like
well experience to talk about the turtle
princess had said something like you're
so good I bet you could even get Finn
okay okay per year love stirs right yeah
it's something around those lines like
she could if she can get where she wants
to and everyone wants Finn yes I just
you know get Finn to like you and then
write about it and then I can learn from
what you did so she goes on these uh at
least one adventure with Finn and Jake
and she gets sucked into the mirror she
goes in the mirror and then these are
shadowy people come out and Finn saves
her and she realizes hey what's the hot
one oh my god and my impression is just
died I apologize I start off good that
died you know and she writes a book
about that and I yeah I can't just wait
I'm trying remember even how this air
like it was something funny yeah oh yeah
that's right and Jake says let's be your
word garbage just be your word garbage
what the hell are you doing just
abandoned us giving his hot okay this is
what we do for fun you play with garbage
yes you'll join us have the bag yeah
okay I think the last episode start
lovely Space Princess really like put me
in the wrong direction because it was
better I was not fond of the last LSP
one but this one this was much better I
guess I think because it cracks me the
hell up
I guess you know cuz I dunno and I have
no people right okay who who really do
think really seriously think that they
are so freakin amazing like anybody that
looks in their general direction you see
him you see I mean I was in high school
with girls like that you see him he's
looking at me he totally wants me like
totally happy like it just it cracks me
up it's an exaggeration but at the same
time it just it cracks me up okay
thought it was funny and I really liked
you know the part where Finn is like
well you know but your lumps are on the
inside and they're great your brain is
still beautiful on the inside and oh my
god and it's funny but it's sweet I like
it when they I like when they address a
cliche but it also kind of makes it work
like I like what he says yeah don't you
know it's the lumps are inside like your
brain and stuff yeah like he doesn't
need to say the rest cuz you know how
the rest of it goes what it's still you
know it's still coming from a good
character you like you can yeah okay
like that that works oh my god you're
hot normally like when so assistants
like you know it's your intellect and
your sense of humor that I really like
and it's like yeah oh yeah
you're right though your brain and stuff
late doesn't matter just that the two
things I I did like I actually liked
more than one on the adventure I like
him throwing the stones seeing where the
path is and that I don't I feel very
Zelda to the hour I'm sure it's from
other stuff too obviously I don't know
something you instilled it it I don't
know it just it's a good game it's a
good fancy game
wink wink yeah we just happen to wear
the exact same clothes every single ones
like three shirts yeah
next one XP log I will be our next set
of Velux I'll be showing off my newest
shirt from Jason line yes it's the best
job like sorry go on
oh but yeah I mean it I like that I like
when they went into the bad sort of
world of mirrors or whatever it actually
that remind me of strange comparison
remind me of the second Conan movie oh
yeah yeah remember there's the guy the
mirrors and then like you throws the
sword in and they have to find the right
here and kills oh very something so so
you're making a comparison with throwing
the stones to find a path to Zelda sorry
to go path took baths to go back to that
but what about like wasn't it Indiana
Jones well no there's something about
like you know over here no the kid dad
over here know the way okay and then you
sort of a it's like the trial and error
sort of thing I think in account even
though they've got like the little
skulls in the water that's like so you
see in a Zelda game like touch here you
die you know sort of thing so it might
be a little bit more of a video game
like maybe not necessarily Zelda but
something along those lines you know
just doing the trial and error I'll turn
you remember what movie was it the
stones and then the camera kind of pants
and you can now see that it is yeah
that's a new yeah no you can't right um
so I like those two things yeah I'm just
I'm Kim can't say give us be a cassock
of turbo princess oh she's probably a
lot more her than we see your tongue all
the way it's our like my god she's also
chemo Phillips yeah a little bit how
about you Joey you liked it yeah I
thought it was really cute um like I
said but I I guess I just have a just a
an odd sense of humor and and I know it
should be annoying but I just I just got
a kick out of it just the little things
like with the air oh my god look my
strap fell and then there's one point
where she's like she makes it so that
you know there's a big lump on her
shoulder and she's like shaking it's
stupid but I don't know that was that
was funny to me that her trying to
seduce Finn was it was too damn funny
hey do you know where garbage to try to
seduce me um that's how I got you to
marry me wait a minute
coverage attracts garbage yeah I'm okay
with that that's not like an eastwood
like garbage a chance killer bitch I
have to say it was creepy it was a very
creepy sexy Finn in the mirror the way
takes the hat off creepy creepy because
he was portrayed as sexy or is it sexy
because it was creepy no it was creepy
because I have my first response was
well that's kind of sexy oh really quick
she's also a fan of like k-pop groups
where they are like 14 No yes they are
18 I make sure that they are sure you do
at least usually they're in their
twenties so it's okay how about you
Jason you've been quiet about this
episode yeah
it was terrible
she's not as bad as tree trunks but
she's she's up there um again she can't
carry an episode and when the main focus
is on her it gets annoying and it gets
old really fast it just seems like the
delivery kind of changes and maybe it is
because we just see marker or whatever
but it almost sounds to me like when
it's kind of like that thing where when
you have one line or just a couple lies
you can put a lot more emphasis and
focus out to make them sound funny yeah
but we have a whole episode it's much
harder to make the deliveries fine
because you don't have as much time it's
like cuts onion you as may takes on this
line because I have to do this line
that's not all these other lines so yeah
maybe it's just a very particular kind
of delivery or amount of time that she
should be allowed because yeah I can't
pump the same way I couldn't get it's
not just that it's her character is very
OneNote it's like okay she talks about
her lumps and her lumps and that's it
like that's all her character really is
I guess the best way can compare it is
with the ringtone turtle princess's
ringtone hey hey girl the first time I
heard it I'm like that's funny
but the second time okay whatever third
time I'm like why yeah like that's
really a nice where I start lost to a
turtle princess - I'm just like well I
don't think I like you know yeah and
that's why I thing with like with lumpy
Space Princess for a whole episode is
that in the beginning or the first time
she shows up for a little bit it's funny
oh she's hilarious I love the way this
is going on and then halfway through
you're like I get it you're still kind
of doing the same things the end it's
like yeah you're still doing the same
things please do something different
characters yes yeah but don't build it
you like episode around that yeah I dug
yeah sorry I just okay I shouldn't say
sorry because well no I think you should
yeah like you should no don't do it
please don't touch my lumps okay that's
the person you want to come into the
field the dog did you valued for her
opinion no it's nothing to do with
opinions
he likes my lumps yeah that's what it is
they're pretty nice see I told you thank
you I know so this is sexy